everyone's first question would be how
do you get a wire from one building to
another if the wire is strong enough to
hold your weight
not that you're heavy but if it's strong
enough to hold your weight you can't
you're not you can't just feed it well
in the case of the world trend setter
how do you Pastor the cable across
silently and quickly how you do it but
you know what I'm gonna answer with a
visual thing because I did something
good you have I brought the historic bow
and that's the boat that z-bo which is
actually it cheap you know plastic thing
in two parts which was input really in a
blueprint tube because my friends were
disguised as architect and that's the
arrow and I know the scientist in you is
not going to ask me what did you pad at
the end it's obvious right shooty to
someone else my accomplice on the North
Tower shot the bow and arrow to which
was attached a fishing line imagine that
in the middle of the night crawling on
the South Tower in complete darkness
you're looking for a fishing line that
in itself is a movie scene which is
actually in a movie and this is a you
know this was for my trunk and yours at
first what do I let you touch it for you
if you second thanks so anyway okay so
so now that's the fishing line and
presumably at this point the cable is
just dangling straight down the cable is
still in a South Tower ready to be paid
off and what I need when I got the
fishing line I need to pay off a Cordina
a little rope and then they got the
little group and they attached a big
rope they sent it to me and to the big
rope I cannot touch the very holy cable
so it was that all night of rigging
because the fishing line is not strong
enough to hold the weight of the cable
but it gets but it connects you exactly
connects yeah it creates it's the it's
the engagement ring you know in America
I love that you say that because very
often the poet in me cannot resist
describing what happened by saying I saw
the Twin Towers being born I got the
idea before they were born
I saw them grow up and when they were
adult I married them with a smile of my
cat in a week
so marriage wing we own in the same
store yes yes that it's it's romantic
indeed
well French are very romantic